[音楽]
私たちには様々な
悩みに直面します
ある大学の友人は
大学なじみ day
ゼミ生と共同で資料を作ったり発表したり
するのが
ember に気を使うと
会うたびに言っています
また戦績だった別な友人は
バイト先の同僚や上司の空気がピリピリし
ていて
バイトに池永行くだと嘆いていました
また同じ勉強会で活動している社会人の方
も
同僚の空気が合わず
転職を考えていると
仰ってみましょう
皆さんはこれなぜ悩みに共通するものは何
だと思われますか
私もいろいろ考えましたが
これらに共通するものはすべて人間関係の
悩みであるということだと思います
みなさんがこのような悩みを感じた時本屋
さんに行けばコミュニケーションについて
の本が並んでいます
ネットを検索すれば
寝台ような記事が見つかります
もしかすると皆さんの中でも
コミュニケーションが絶対にうまくいくと
うたう本を立ち読みしたり
google 芸作でバイト先
コミュニケーションと調べたりしたことが
あるっていう方もいらっしゃるんじゃない
でしょうか
例えば目線を合わせるということは相手の
話を真剣に聞いている証たも言われてい
ます
私自身コミュニケーションや人間関係に
ついてさまざまな悩みがありたくさんの
書籍やウェブページを読み調べた結果
目線を合わせる
ということを実践してみた一人です
しかし先天性緑内障の影響で1歳半から
全盲として清潔してきた私にとって
目線を合わせる
という行為は大変難しい作業でした
ここで私は
相手が発した言葉に着目して
コミュニケーションをとってみようと
思い立ちました
例えば高校生の頃の生徒会活動では
後輩から聞かれたし質問に対して人一倍
相手が発した言葉に着目して回答してい
ました
しかし
相手が発した言葉に寂蒔した結果
相手の細かな表現や言い方に敏感になり
すぎて
自分の感情が不安定になることが増えまし
た
それと同時に
複数の同級生や後輩が
私のことを論理的だが厳しい人だと
入っているのを耳にしてしまいました
相手と誠実に向き合いたくて言葉に敏感に
なっていたのに
さの想いは相手に届いていないと
実感した瞬間でした
今までお話ししてきたように
コミュニケーション上だけの既存の方法は
2つに分類できると思います
一つ目は
目線を合わせる
文字を聞かうのような資格情報に着目する
というもの
もう一つは
相手が発した言葉や恋のような
聴覚情報に着目するというものです
良いコミュニケーションについて
様々な情報が出回っています
私自身
コミュニケーションにおいて何が重要なの
か分からないまま
気づけば
台が鉄になっていました
そこで私は大きな
カルチャーショックを受けました
たくさんの大学生がスマートフォンの写真
や動画を見せ合って会話教えたためです
例えばこんな会話です
昨日ここに行ってきてめっちゃ綺麗だった
よ
そうだね私はここに行ってきたよほら
こんな感じ
すごいなぁ
このようなかように出会うたびに
今回はに私が加わったら迷惑かなと考える
ようになりました
なぜなら目の見えない私が指示語をよく買
写真や動画を見せるような会話に参加する
と
逐一状況を説明してもらわないといけない
ためです
もしかすると私が思っている以上に親切な
人が多くて写真の説明を面倒くさがる口に
してくれるかもしれない
しかし y 様から毎回私のためだけに
説明をお願いするのは気がしている
そんなことを考えているうちによく声を
かけてくれてる人いた人も新たな友人を
見つけ
私は大学で一人で過ごす時間が増えていき
ました
分は法律が勉強したくて大学駅た
人間関係の悩みがちなとぐらいなら友達
なんて行きたくてもいい
そう考えるようになりました
しかしそれが本心でないことは
自分が一番わかっていました
そんなとき
とても透き通った雇用した一人の女性に
出会いました
彼女の名前は伊万里で私と同級生でした
授業で私の資格情報を補うサポーターをし
てくれたのが接点でお互い英語や留学に
興味を持っていたことから
すぐに打ち解け親しくなりました
彼女は良くはない
人を褒めることができ
しかし同時に自分の意見をしっかりと主張
できる女性でした
そんな今には存在が友人なんていらないと
思っていた自分の心
少し開いていきました
伊万里と出会ってから
1年が経った頃のことでしょうか
彼女からどうしても話したいことがあると
いう連絡がありました
その深刻そうな面持ちから良くないことが
起きたのは明らかでした
実は
友人が交通事故で亡くなった
そう告げられました
何も話さなくていいから大学に入るときは
以前より頻繁に会ってほしい
夜に感情的になりやすいからそんな時は
電話をつないでいて欲しい
仕事が生まれました
自分は何をしていいのか
伊万里のために何ができるのかわかりませ
んでしたか
文を信頼してたよってくれた気持ちに
よりされたいと思いました
自分自身
過去に親しくいてしていた先輩を病気で
亡くすという経験をしていたためです
その時の気持ちが蘇りました
もうその先輩とはえない
喧嘩することすらできない
そして何より常に連絡を取り合わなくても
相手の存在すかなものだ
自分の先生になっていたと気づかされまし
た
当たり前のように目の前にあったものが
なくなり
当たり前だったことが当たり前でないとき
ずつ
さのような絶望の中でスターズ実雄
誰かに打ち上げることは総評以上に難しい
ことでした
だからこそ
伊万里が友人を亡くして苦しんだそれまで
の期間
自分にどうやって表弾しようかと苦悩して
こと
そのような気持ちに
やり替えたいと思いました
実際に会ったり電話したりした時に交わし
た会話はたわいもないもので
ほとんどがお互い何も話していない時間
でしたがガー
言葉がなくても
お互いの気持ちが通じ合っているという
感覚がありました
そして
少しいっ
笑顔を見せることが増えていくにマリオ
未定
ほっとしました
金具この出来事をきっかけに彼女とは
楽しかったことだけではなく
お互いの失敗や弱みもさらけ出して共有
するような関係になりました
月日は流れ私たちが大学3年生の時
私は大変嬉しい報せを受けておりました
なんと東京2021
オリンピックパラリンピックの
聖火リレーのランダーに選出されたのです
私のような専門の人が聖火リレーを走る際
には私の目の代わりとなってガイドして
くれる盤表車と共に参加できる
という制度があります
だり2番フォークお願いしようか考えた
とき
たくさんの時間を過ごし
いろんな思いを共有してきた
今人しかいないと感じました
他の知らせを鍛える前から喜んでくれる
世界が姿が浮かんできたからです
彼女がかな場にいないのに
彼女の気持ちが手に取るように想像でき
自然と彼女の気持ちに思いを馳せることが
できました
私が
正解デーという二度とないかもしれない
イベントは
大切な人と思い出を共有したい
表伝えました
今リオ
聖火リレーに出られることもうれしい
けれど
それ以上に自分のことを一番に考えて連絡
をくれたことがうれしい
と答えてくれました
言葉ではうまく説明することができない
自分の気持ちに
彼女も思いを馳せてくれました
皆さんに一つ表情していただきたいことが
あります
皆さんが来プレゼントとして友人から
犬の顔とシッポが利いたティッシュ系譜を
もらったとします
このプレゼントをもらった時
どんなことを感じるでしょうか
もしかするとお値段が安いから価値が無い
とか
自分が使う事はないさせたのだから意味が
ないと感じてしまうこともあるかもしれ
ません
しかし
相手がプレゼントを買ってきてくれた
気持ちや
どうやって選んでくれたんだろうという
ことに思いをはせると
今まで見えていなかったことに気づくかも
しれません
あなたの友人は
あなたが最近疲れているようかないつかれ
ているようだから
少しでも
笑顔になってほしいと思ったから
犬のピッシュ系譜を買ってきてくれたのか
もしれませんし
最近仕事が大変そうだから
少しでも癒やしを与えたいと思ったからか
もしれません
逆に私たちがプレゼントを選ぶときを表し
ても
この服は似合うかなとか
債券惹かれているようだからリラックス
できるものをプレゼントしようとか
気づかないうちに相手の想いに気持ちを
はせていた
そんな経験はありませんか
コミュニケーションも
これと同じだと思います
プレゼントをもらった時あ
選ぶ時に
相手の気持ちに思いをはせるように
相手が来たの話を振るまでに思い悩んだか
デー
自分を信頼してたよってくれた勇気
というような気持ちに
思いを馳せるのが大切だと思います
確かに思いをはせる
ということは抽象的です
今日
今すぐにできるというものではありません
さらにコミュニケーションにはさまざまな
要素が絡み合ってより本読んだりネットを
調べたりして今すぐに上手くいくという
ものでもありません
だからこそを思いをはせるということが今
すぐにできなくても
何か対人関係で問題にぶつかったときや
誰かから相談を受けたとき
このメッセージを思い出してください
伊万里との出会いが
と世タレかけていた私の心を開き
人に思いをはせるとはどういうことなのか
を教えてくれました
私が相手の気持ちに
思いをはせられるようになるにつれ
気付けば私のマーリンウェア
お互いの思いを尊重し合える大切な友人が
1人
また一人と増えていきました
私が何か問題に直面したとき
ぜひ他にあって言葉を交わさなくても
大切な人たちとの思い出を振り返り
思いを馳せることで
また明日から
一歩ずつ前に進んでみよう
自分は常に大切な人に支えられている
と勇気づけられました
皆さんにとって
大切な人は
誰ですか
今思い浮かべてくださった方から
今
一番聞きたいことは
何ですか
そしてその方に
一番伝えたいことは
何ですか
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]